sentados en fila y Entre llantos y
abrazos empujara los familiares de las
víctimas del accidente aéreo esperan a
recibir los cuerpos de sus seres
queridos el vuelo que partió de katmandú
solo duraba 27 minutos pero nunca llegó
nuestra familia está profundamente
devastada ahora mismo no soy capaz de
pensar en cómo voy a consolar al resto
de la familia y algo
Antes de aterrizar en la ciudad de
pujara el piloto pidió
un poco antes de una explosión que hizo
que el avión se estrellara por el
momento se ha confirmado que no hubo
ningún fallo técnico y las causas del
accidente son aún desconocidas pero tras
Hallar las dos cajas negras del avión se
espera que éstas salgan a la luz en los
próximos días de las 72 personas que
viajaban en la aeronave se han
recuperado 70 cuerpos si el Gobierno ya
ha advertido que encontrara las dos
personas que faltan con vida es
prácticamente imposible
la noche anterior recogimos 63 cadáveres
y los llevamos al hospital sin embargo
ayer se localizaron otros tres pero no
se pudieron recuperar o ya hemos
recuperado seis cuerpos y seguimos
buscando otros dos desaparecidos
y es que junto a las condiciones
climáticas adversas los equipos de
rescate han visto dificultado su trabajo
por el terreno montañoso por lo que la
operación hacía suspendido por el
momento Este es el peor accidente aéreo
del país en 30 años y ha dejado a la
población conmocionada